bonjour et bienvenue sur diagonale tv
spéciale grand champion de l'histoire du
jeu d'échecs et aujourd'hui on accueille
jérôme maufras salut fis ron wilson
alors on va voir un super champion puis
alors un champion atypique puisque c'est
un autre côté de la planète qui fait son
apparition avec lui et oui c'est un
champion asiatiques
pissevin attendre anand qui est indien
voilà donc ça alors ça c'est tout à fait
étonnant puisque depuis le début de
l'histoire des grands champions d'échecs
très peu d'asiatiques apparaissent c'est
surtout des européens des américains un
peu de sud américains avec making dans
les années 70 nash dorff d'origine
polonaise mais qui vit en argentine et
pad asiatique quoi et là alors dans les
années 20 déjà y avait quand même dans
les années 20 30 qui avaient déjà une
exception c'était sultane cannes sultane
gamme qui était il y avait la
particularité d'être à la fois un
serviteur au service d'un lord anglais
et puis un joueur d'échecs génial
sorties dont de ségou c'est ça qui a
joué quelques années au plus haut niveau
et qui repartit on ne sait où ensuite
météores
j'ai pas dire incompréhensible inédit
alors c'est pas le premier individu un
peu incompréhensible qui s'ordonne j'ai
souvenir aussi dans les mathématiques
il avait au début du 20e siècle un
mathématicien génial de pareilles ne
savais pas du tout d'où il sortait
c'était ramanujan il s'appelait et donc
lille et les indiens parfois ce sont des
génies un peu comme ça à la bobby
fischer oui parce qu'il n'y a pas deux
il y avait pas de tradition particulière
du jeu d'échecs en inde
si ce n'est qu'on peut préciser quand
même que les premiers jeux qui ressemble
au jeu d'échecs l'ancêtre du jeu
d'échecs le château en ga aurait été
inventé en inde au 6è 7è siècle soit le
siècle après jésus-christ mais s'est pas
maintenue spécifiquement une tradition
de grands joueurs indiens par la suite
au moyen-âge ou la renaissance au à
l'époque moderne
sultane cannes tu sors d'un terrain
quasiment vierge et de la même façon
allende et le résultat une trajectoire
plus individuelle que d'une école
spécifique quand on a eu l'école
soviétique ou comme on a toute l'europe
centrale qui a toujours fourni depuis un
siècle un siècle et demi des grands
champions oui horde ou sultane cannes
effectivement les années 30
et cette sorte de
d'exception bizarre qui arrive dans le
monde des échecs qui fait d un très très
bon joueur exceptionnel donc il n'a pas
pu avoir la carrière qu'il aurait sans
doute voulu puisqu'il était au service
de quelqu'un d'autre il ne pouvait pas
se libérer comme il voulait et il ya un
vide après c'est à dire qu'il ya pas
avec sultane cannes la création d'une
lignée de champions ya rien et c'est à
nantes qui apparaît alors comme un
appareil à un dîner quand comment un an
qu'on se déroule son aventure parce qu
est ce qui est étonnant c'est que c'est
vraiment un
c'est un météore il disait sa
progression est fulgurante et mais à la
fois très régulière arriver à 70 en 1969
et dès 14 ans il est en ce qui est
logique il est champion du monde cadets
en inde il ya quinze ans il lui maître
international à 16 ans et gagne le
championnat du monde adulte indien
tranquille bonsoir la limite
oui la limite bon il faut quand même
réussir à s'imposer à 18 ans à baguio
city aux philippines dieu d'annoncer aux
championnats du monde en 78 il devient
champion du monde juniors sait déjà
c'est déjà un accomplissement parce
qu'on sait que tous les champions du
monde quasiment depuis espace qui
quasiment sont auparavant on sont
devenus champions du monde juniors oui
donc c'est souvent l'antichambre d'une
grande carrière par la suite et le
premier asiatique à devenir champion du
monde junior c'est déjà une première
nouveauté
à 19 ans il devient grand maître
international à 20 ans il termine
premier au tournoi de michaels et c'est
sa première victoire avec casey mais
c'est pas la seule puisque il a gagné en
tout cinq fois ce super tournoi
oui donc ça n'augurait toute une série
et à l'âge de 21 ans il est déjà
candidat pour le titre de champion du
monde oui puisqu'il rencontre pendant
les matchs des candidats qui doivent
préparer le match 93e rang contre
kharkov
oui et il est battu seulement 2 1 par un
atelier car peuvent donc déjà un il est
pas il est pas surclassé il est juste
battu battu d'un point c'est presque une
surprise je me rappelle à l'époque
enfin je crois que à ce moment là on
croyait même qu'alain ne pouvait battre
car prof tellement il était fort et
peut-être oublié de dire une
caractéristique d'un an dès le début de
sa carrière c'est qu'il joue super vite
et joue très très vite très vite l on
appelle le blitzkrieg
falla le dialogue c'est clair où le
lucky luke pour arte la série les échecs
en il est l'homme qui joue plus vite que
son ombre
tellement il jouer vite à dire qu'il
prenait quoique 45 minutes à la pendule
sur son capital de 2h30 quoi ils
prenaient presque rien donc c'est un
joueur je voir des attaques hors pair il
a remporté de nombreux tournois en
glisse et puis j'étais très très fort
aussi l aveugle il a remporté beaucoup
de tournois que le melody amber qui
était un tournoi à l'aveuglé championnat
du monde deux parties rapides aussi
comme en 2003 au cap d'agde donc c'est
un joueur que cette particularité
effectivement de jouer très très vite
devoir très vite les meilleurs coups et
je me souviens aussi qu'elle cette
époque ont considéré qu'il pouvait
devenir très vite champion du monde oui
c'est vrai vie tout à fait on
s'attendait à ce que puissent éclore
encore plus vite alors il ya ce match
qui perd contre karpov mais il a une
levée nouveau une chance et pas la
moindre puisque en 95 il a 26 ans il se
qualifie pour affronter garry kasparov à
new york ça y est me pour le titre
mondial
oui et on s'attend à un match finalement
super tendu et des pâtes pas pas
tellement en fait finalement ils
n'arrivent pas non plus vite non
kasparov repent prendre la mesure de son
adversaire
l'écart n'est pas gigantesque je crois
10 et demi à cet ennemi garry kasparov
contre allende
mais un homme n'a pas sa chance dans ce
match clairement kasparov et au dessus
et il manque encore quelque chose allant
de calcul très vite il est très fort
pour tous les dossiers tactique mais
peut-être qu'il manque encore un petit
peu de cette de la profondeur de jeu qui
est nécessaire pour devenir champion du
monde
sans doute et puis alors il s'est rendu
compte un peu à la talent d'ailleurs
quand durant la visite de talent qui
parfois y il forcé trop les positions
pour essayer de gagner alors lui bon ont
annoncé qu'ils prenaient pas assez de
temps et il a dit qu' on a vu aussi mais
il s'est rendu compte finalement qu'il
avait qui produisent et de meilleurs
résultats quand il a commencé
finalement à piocher son capital temps
et arrêter de jouer aussi vite
finalement aidé au mieux réfléchir plus
en plus en profondeur à ses coûts et
peut-être aussi qu'il y avait une
caractéristique qui faisait d'un an de 1
excellent candidat au titre mondial à
qui il manquait encore quand même cela
la volonté de vaincre de finalement de
d'écraser l'adversaire parce que à
nantes finalement il connut aussi pour
être un joueur extrêmement affable
gentil en dehors de l'échiquier il
cherche pas c'est quelqu'un qui joue
vraiment pour le plaisir de jouer et qui
n'a pas comme kasparov et karpov la
volonté de domination qui est qui qui
était assez clair chez eux
oui ou ceux fischer qui aimait voir
légaux de l'adversaire se briser
plus quand il jouait le coup gagnant à
nantes c'est pas du tout ça c'est plutôt
dire quelqu'un de pacifique et c'est
vrai que pour être champion du monde je
pense qu'il faut avoir une une âme un
petit peu plus guerrière de deux
combattants
peut-être qu'il a mis du temps aussi à
se forger ce moral de ce moral de
vainqueur et c'est le rôle de tueur sur
l'échiquier en tout cas alors donc 95 il
échoue lors de sept de ce championnat du
monde classique face à carpes à face à
kasparov
mais il va en fait non seulement
continuent à lire des tournois ça s'est
su on y joue toujours dans les plus
grands tournois du monde
linarès avec andy dortmund où il a joué
aura joué plusieurs fois et mais il va
avoir sa chance dans le championnat du
monde fit défiler dans 98 contre car
peuvent donc il ya une scission il faut
rappeler scission championnat du monde
de kasparov était parti il a joué contre
short et contre allende
en dehors du cycle et la fidh et a dû
réorganiser des matchs avec et les
perdants avec art aux faits et imane à
l'époque et puis après encore karpov et
un homme d'ailleurs il a battu à langnau
première fois et puis les successions
comme ça de champion mais finalement oui
qu'on a envie de dire de seconde zone
parce que kalichman que le champion du
monde et non c'était pas un scénario
simon ponomariov bond moyson les oublié
tellement il y en a eu d'ailleurs mais
ils n'ont pas forcément
c'était laisser une empreinte parce que
le quand il ya deux championnats du
monde comme ça on perd en visibilité
sévilla sûr mais avant de finir lui
quand même par par obtenir ce titre
filets ce titre fidh et tient en 2007 au
moment de la réunification mais je crois
il appartenait ans et je crois même si
je crois que je suis plus en quelle date
et non en 2000 je sais plus s'il passe
il n'avait pas battu fini par battre car
profond n'ont peut-être pas je me crois
que non je crois qu'ils ont c'est là
coup de genou alors qu'il a gagné oui
ils ont fait match nul contre avec
karpov en 2000 98 mais je crois car
peuvent l'emporter au départage oui
c'est ça c'était c'était c'était ça
s'est joué à très peu de la très peu de
coups et c'est en 2007 qu'il gagne le
titre réunifiée avec le fameux tournoi
il ya un tournoi 8 qui organisait à
mexico en 2007 parce que parce que
chronique est champion du monde accepte
les conditions parce que c'est le moment
qui tu veux ça et donc réunification du
titre en 2007
ça se fait à l'occasion d'un grand
tournoi avec les huit meilleurs joueurs
du monde quasiment de l'époque un petit
peu comme le tournoi de 48 avait permis
de désigner bobigny comme champion du
monde est bien là allende l'emportent
devant chronique eagle ford et devient
champion du monde réunifiée en 2007 et
titres qu'il détient deux cuisses
maintenant quand on fait l'émission mais
en 2012 c'est le champion du monde
régnant ils viennent défendre d'ailleurs
son titre face à elle fonde alors il a
défendu trois fois depuis 2007
oui il a défendu une première fois
contre 1 contre cramique oui alors là il
a réussi à on avait dit que chrome ni
qui avait battu kasparov notamment sur
la défense parce que chronique joue un
jeu très solide en 2000 la à l'inde à
trouver les clés pour battre
granby puisqu'il emporte hills et demi
quatre et demi donc son jeu de
d'intact riant un peu de des positions
très solide de chronique depuis un an
deux défaites pas l'ofs
ce qui lui permet de conserver son titre
hélas en août 2012 il va quelle fin
récemment il vagal forme d'eau dans les
matchs de départage c'était quand même
un peu serré et garde son titre
donc ça fait quand même cinq ans qu'il
est champion du monde dans un contexte
qui est quand même très concurrentiel
parce que oui
là il a beau être champion du monde il
doit être à peu près cinquième au
classement mondial oui et la densité au
dessus des 2700 lots et tels que les
balades les niveaux se tiennent et que
la concurrence est très rude
alors oui on attend pour l'instant on
attend le moment où magnus carlsen
lui-même qui semble être le véritable
nouveau météores des échecs finissent
par jouer un match face à nantes c'est
ce qu'on rêve parce que si c'est un
tournoi qui décide du titre est bien sâr
perdra de sa finalement de sa superbe
quant à la filiation historique du titre
classique alors à noter une petite
anecdote avec un an parce que moi j'ai
eu la chance de 2min herviou vais tout
simplement pour diagonale télé plusieurs
fois dans plusieurs endroits et
notamment avec anzhi
on était allé donc à l'époque c'était
avec le grand maître et loire où l'ange
qui participait à diagonale tv donc ça
devait être en 99 francs en 2000 dans
l'est dans l'émission spéciale vacances
et de l'époque on a une interview d'un
land et au départ il voulait pas faire
l'interview s'est vexé après sa partie
bon il devait peut-être fatigué
peut-être il n'avait pas envie
il voulait pas répondre je sais pas et
mais auparavant on avait discuté avec sa
femme c'est la con
vous voulez parler un peu de sa femme
haruna parce qu'on la voit souvent dans
les tourments elle est toujours présente
c'est pas toujours le cas les joueurs ne
pas toujours leur femme a vécu qui
accompagne mais là si vous n'avez
toujours là on la voit toujours sous
très souvent d'ailleurs sur les photos
et tout ça à l'air très très très
important pour lui qu elles
l'accompagnent sur ces événements et
donc on avait discuté indiqué ça s'était
très bien passé elle était assez
contente et ses devoirs qu'on voulait
s'intéresser à son mari à l'époque était
pas encore champion du monde non même si
c'était déjà bien sûr une légende un du
jeu bien sûr et est finalement donc
appris la partie on demande à nantes si
donc il accepte de faire une interview
de répondre à quelques questions
et puis bon il a pas envie on fait un
peu la moue sont bas et à ce moment là
haruna qui est sa femme qui était avec
nous comment c'est à dire à nantes comme
ça en faisait un petit reproche gentille
et quoi et du coup les sirops tournée il
dit bon on va la faire voir ces warrants
et puis c'est à noter qu'elle l'a appelé
à nantes
et parce que c'est un des facteurs aussi
qu'on a oublié de dire c'est que le vrai
nom de famille
danang c'est pas un homme sévit cheval
atteint en fait son prénom c'est un land
en fait ils s'appellent allant de viva
nhat hanh tout comme on à garry kasparov
donc on l'appelle depuis le début on l'a
appelée à nantes pour des raisons que
tout mignon il n'a jamais vraiment tenu
à corriger ça parce que c'est plus
facile à prononcer pour nous je crois
oui mais c'est rare quand même bref d'un
côté on a bien et shakira nous déléguons
des noms imprononçables où il est arrivé
il ya un joueur qui s'appelait rectifie
je crois qu'il ya des noms quand même à
rallonge aussi qui existe mais je veux
atteindre mon pourquoi pas c'est quand
même
ceci passe il ya d'autres exemples
l'histoire du jeu d'échecs comme ça où
un joueur dans les listes officielles
d'ailleurs océane en quoi c'est un an
c'est comme si on disait un gary
anatolie voilà c'est ça fait un peu
bizarre quoi c'est vrai voilà donc à non
on va voir quelques photos maintenant de
ce don très grand champion indien donc
on voit ici en train de jouer le chess
classics sans doute de dortmund ou de
mayence poney ans mais de mayence en
allemagne alors à noter on voit son
drapeau indien on peut rappeler alors
d'ailleurs ce drapeau à nyala petit
roullens et la roue c'est la roue du
dharma bouddhiste un qui fait kiffer le
centre de la roue du karma quoi la roue
qui tourne c'est le symbole de drapeaux
indiens comme ça bon c'est un petit
détail est à noter que la nand quand il
revient en inde après ses titres de
champion du monde après ses résultats
est accueilli comme une très grande
vedette
oui et en inde il y là y compris des
contrats publicitaires il fait des
publicités
pour par exemple des microprocesseurs il
a fait ou pour des boissons ou ce genre
de choses ou d'énergétique oui et puis
j'ai des compléments alimentaires à base
de phosphore ce genre de choses donc il
est là il est très populaire en inde un
il est populaire il est souvent dans les
journaux et ses titres sont en hausse
ont célébré comme tel dans un pays qui
n'a pas une très très grande tradition
sportive par ailleurs oui il ya enfin
disons que les sports en haine sont
moins connus chez nous je crois que
c'est leur alors leur leur sport numéro
1 c'est le hockey sur gazon qui s'il se
bat avec lee qui allait avec les
hollandais je crois qu'ils sont si
j'étais socialiste de ça et puis c'est
tout voilà parce que ça intéresse
personne d'autre mais ça ça vient aussi
de leur histoire voilà c'est vrai que
l'aisne n'est pas allée pas
spécifiquement axé sur les sports les
ondes traditionnelles mais aux échecs
sayedi son coin alors à noter aussi
qu'on a parlé dans l'histoire du jeu du
glissement comme ça des grands champions
d'échecs vers les nations qui finalement
fini domine le monde
économique et politique on a les chinois
qui monte en puissance y compris chez
les hommes d'ailleurs mais qui
détiennent les titres féminins
ça fait quelques années maintenant qu'il
commence à pousser chez les titres
féminins et la champion du monde
féminine est une chinoise c'est willy
fans qui d'ailleurs a battu judit polgar
très récemment donc ça veut dire qu'elle
a un énorme potentiel et et chez les
hommes mais ils ont ils ont alors par
contre derrière suis pas sûr qu'ils
aient un champion du monde vite s'il ya
un an de perd son titre
non c'est pas par un grand grand
mouvement encore mais je sais que
hollande
ah non pas une fondation mais il est à
la tête d'un projet pour le
développement du jeu d'échecs à l'école
en inde donc ça va peut-être lui même se
mêler les graines qui vont tendre les
graines de champions qui vont éclore
d'ici 10 15 ou 20 ans oui alors ceci dit
après avec un milliard d'habitants ça
peut aller vite
ça peut aller très très vite alors donc
ici donc attendre encore un an bien sûr
un autre tournoi ici toujours à mayence
d'ailleurs mais c'est sans doute pas le
même c'est là pas la même année donc
toujours drapeau n'diaye les lunettes
elle reçoit une des mines est alors là
c'est sans doute l'olympiade puisqu'il a
le il tient le maillot et le polo
officiel de l'équipe dans le pool
officiels et les teams d'inde
elle est magnifique cette photo je la
trouve superbe donc que c'est en dirait
vraiment là c'est un sport on voit bien
sportif de l'esprit comme un billet
sports lille et il est à fond on sent
que la tension là il réfléchit la
positionnant à l'air tendu avec le fou
ou 8 luron hashemite way va y avoir du
calcul ça doit chauffer sous le sous le
cuir chevelu 1 donc on sent qu'il est il
est tendu comme peut l'être un champion
en bande avant de tirer un penalty par
exemple un pour le foot
et on sent que ça ça ça tient alors
évidemment c'est moins moins physique au
terme de lui vincent mais on voit la
tension et la superbe photo voilà encore
une photo ici donc on note encore ici le
l'échiquier lectronique a envoyé le
petit câble qui a devant les pièces et
bien permet de récupérer en temps réel
la position de toutes les pièces sur
l'échiquier pour les retransmettre sur
seront un écran et que le public puisse
suivre les parties en temps réel que ce
soit sur place dans la salle où
maintenant désormais sur aussi sur
internet
c'est on peut le signaler quand même un
des rares joueurs à avoir atteint le
classement de 2800 il a été classé 2805
crois que c'est un privilège qui partage
avec garry kasparov
oui écrit c'est magnus carlsen je crois
récemment travnik aussi abattu
simplement est aussi question plusieurs
ils sont plus et c'est un club quand
même très très fermé oui
deux joueurs qui ont pu atteindre ce
classement il atteint deux fois en 2006
et en 2007 à demi nue ça veut dire quoi
il faut rappeler ce que ça veut dire
c'est là qu'un joueur qu'à 2806 joue
face à un joueur qui à 2500
théoriquement si les proportions sont
maintenus ça signifie quelque chose
comme 80 % ou 85 % de chances de gain
face aux joueurs c'est assez énorme sur
tea party ces huit et demi sur dix vols
un bon il n'ya pas de mal quoi c'est un
écrasement 300 poignet car c'est tout à
fait énorme sénat déjà 100 points ça
doit être de l'ordre de 60 40 55 45 100
points ce niveau là c'est beaucoup et
c'est déjà beaucoup
voilà et on revient la première image
ici avec le petit petits trous toujours
qu'il trouve la petite roue du dharma ou
du carmin au choix c'est pareil
voilà donc on va venir maintenant à
notre parti du jour pour rendre hommage
à un homme qui n'a pas fini sa carrière
puisqu'il est champion du monde en titre
on va regarder une partie entre un
hollande et kasparov alors lors du
fameux championnat du monde de 1995 qui
s'est joué donc à new york et qui était
déjà oui c'était un c'était une belle
affiche coin c'était vraiment une très
très belle affiche
c'était c'était un des challengers les
plus attendus face à kas parents très
clairement donc un match qui s'est joué
donc qu'on l'avait dit
sous l'ère de la scission des titres la
fille des fédérations tarson les échecs
on continue à organiser un championnat
sans kasparov et kasparov essayer de
monter des matches un peu à la manière
des boxeurs en fait en quelque sorte et
s'est trouvé des meilleures bourses pour
jouer face à des challengers choisi ou
qualifiés selon les possibilités qui
avait pour le moins en évidence et c'est
plus dur pour un joueur d'être à la fois
organisateurs et joueurs que de que
faire que jouer c'est kasparov s'est mis
la pression tout seul ce côté là donc
allende à l'eiblen phase 1 kasparov
c'est parti pour 4 c 5 qu'elle lève 3
des 6 des 4 70 et 4 quai les parents des
quatre cas les pcistes tout ça est
normal après calais ces trois à six
on est dans une nage dorff donc ça c'est
typique de kasparov kasparov a gagné
énormément de partie avec cette variante
il est temps de d'empêcher le fou de
venir en v5 ça c'est une chose
on peut voit là on empêche tout en
bessin qu'on veut c'est de jouer
justement de dessin on veut jouer des 5
et perturbé le cavalier ici de façon à
pouvoir gagner du temps contre l'attack
du pion central les noirs vont mettre le
centre sous pression au maximum
éventuellement avec l'aide de faux
bessette ou alors éventuellement avec
une autre manoeuvre qui est cavalier
décès puis cavaliers c5 est aussi en
général très fort et
bon c'est tellement fort que bon c'est
très dur à jouer quoi on fait avec les
blancs alors il faut être précis avec
les noirs font pas faire n'importe quoi
mais c'est une variante extrêmement
incisif qui se joue à quelques coups
c'est très théorique 1 c'est très connu
et très jouer donc il faut faire
attention quand on joue ça donc l'as
outreau coup 36 elana landes
ici il ya plein d'autres variantes que
beaucoup plus agressive on peut jouer ou
g5
on peut jouer parfois des variantes on
peut pourquoi pas tenter des coups comme
g3 faut pas être trop là non plus parce
que attention la pression contre le
centre blanc va aller vite
même si les normands pas descendre une
sortie de pièces ça peut être vite
pénible alors en cours a encore un coup
de pions mais voyez comment les noirs
finalement on en sortira encore aucune
pièce 1 2 3 de la part des blancs et
après petit rock qu'ils ont presque fini
leur développement alors que n'ont pas
commencé mais ils ont un cavalier sortie
ils ont deux pions au centre ou en
opposition capable de jouer soit des
cinq soit eux cinq ils ont la poussée
bessin qui tôt ou tard va gagner du
temps parce qu'une fois qu'on a joué
bambin il faudra peut-être joué à troyes
pour empêcher b4 et on va perdre du
temps ou alors faudra accepter de subir
b4 très vite et d'un autre côté il faut
que les blancs mais profitent de cet
avantage il va falloir qu'il trouve un
plan pour continuer à jouer en ligne
assure donc la fossette de la part de
kasparov bon maintenant que les blancs
ok faut le sait-on peu rauque et du même
côté parce que attention parfois les
blancs choisissent de rock et du grand
côté pascal il ya des attaques des deux
côtés il faut faire attention à 4 alors
ça voilà on voit bien une fois qu on
expliquer pourquoi l'un des cinq camps
toujours à quatre on a bien compris on
va les noirs ne peuvent plus jouer 5 i/s
quand même les deux cavaliers le pion
plus le fou qui vise cette case exercé
une poussée qui ne se produira pas pour
l'instant
voilà donc la casse par ont choisi un
autre type de développement dans cette
partie car elle et ses 6,1 très bien on
sort les cavaliers aussi vous voyez que
ça y est on a déjà trois pièces de
sortie ça va vite un pour le moment ici
photo 3
bon position classique ici souvent dans
ce type de position parfois les blancs
jouent f4 plus mettre la dame est ici en
eux et ils viennent en g3 pour faire
pression et ce côté là c'est un plan
classique petit rock f4 oui ici alors
l'intérêt des f4 ckoi assez bon mais
pourquoi pas ça permet de faire passer
la dame sans me le dire pourquoi pas
c'est aussi de jouer f5 bien sûr surtout
pour faire pression sur le pion aux six
mais vu que le fou et a eu deux bons il
n'est pas il n'a pas été mis en un parce
que on va jouer cinq puis tout si on en
croit ces quatre là c'est pas le cas on
a mis ici donc on contrôle aussi la case
aux 5
pourquoi pas un certaines fois on peut
aussi tenter g4 g5 ça joue aussi pour
déstabiliser de cavaliers mais on
affaiblit le roi blanc bon mais on peut
monter une attaque ça peut arriver
seulement faut faire attention au retour
de bâton
donc il faut y réfléchir à deux fois tam
c'est cette très bien en c'est en
général la case idéal pour la dame noire
ici et par crainte qu'ils veulent et b5
puisque la six qui pilote cette case
d'insurrection on n'a pas peur et calais
b scène et puis on a une petite oeil sur
la case de cinq ici donc à l'ailé pulsé
eux cinq sont affaiblis par la position
de cette dame
à noter qu'on est aussi ici sur une
colonne semi ouverte
pourquoi semi ouverte parce qu'il n'ya
pas de pions noirs mais bien sûr il
reste le pion blanc donc c'est tous
potentiellement à moyen terme une cible
pour les noirs dont cannes en bas âge ou
co le coup oui sans doute le coût
théorique le plus le plus faim ici c'est
le coup h1 pas mal alors pourquoi au
rachat mais vu qu'on a joué f4 on
affaiblit ici cette grande diagonale
donc on veut pas risquer plus tard dans
la partie un petit échec 2
ça peut être utile aussi si parfois on
recule ce fou de 3 sur la case j'aime ça
arrive aussi notamment si ce fou décide
de venir là par exemple plus tard bien
en cas d'un éventuel cavalli g4 se fout
pourrait reculer
bon on n'en est pas là puisque la case
g4 est archi protégé pour l'instant mais
surtout on s'enlève de toute possibilité
d'échec sur cette grande diagonale tours
et là il choisit fouet trois donc tout à
fait classique les blancs jouent en f3
un an de jouer extrêmement solide tout
ça est bien connu c'est archi théorique
archiconnu c'est très solide sur protège
le pion de 4 donc on exerce une grande
pression sur des cinq on empêche toute
velléité des noirs de jouer le coup des
5 c'est pas à l'ordre du jour ni pour
aujourd'hui ni pour demain fou 17 les
noirs finissent leur développement
vous avez vu comme ils affaiblissent
décision décidé de pas faiblir alors
leurs deux pions nous aurait pu choisir
de jouer bessif 17 mais bon il aurait
faiblit un peu cette case
donc ils auraient pu justifier une
poussée f5 un f5 qui affaiblit cette
grande diagonale ici un petit fils quand
même un peu le droit ça peut être
embêtant et puis surtout la casse des
cinq puisque si ce pion ne bouge ou et
prime à la casse des 5 devient une
possibilité pour les blancs de venir
titiller à la casse fait venir des cinq
est un pion arriérés ont des systèmes
assez calme on n'en est pas là on n'est
pas là l'idée là qu'est l'e3 alors
l'idée ici bon il y avait 10 mai 3 c'est
un coup que je sais pas trop expliquer
moi d'un point de vue purement technique
peut-être que l'idée de
de viser la case v6 après à 5 voilà ce
alors que bien sûr il ya cette menace à
5 et peut être tout à fait une vraie
menace à 5 et la case b6 est faible ça
c'est clair d'autant qu'on peut venir
l'occupé par cavalli à quatre cavaliers
b6 aussi avec une fourchette tour fou ça
c'est clair
donc c'est une c'est une prime de ce
point de vue là aussi ça évite bien
coller noir puissent échanger ce cavalli
quand ils veulent maintenant il n'y a
plus de il ya plus de prix donc encore
une petite menace de côté et puis en cas
de cavalia 5 comme le font les noirs ici
pour empêcher la pousser à 5 alors
évidemment si on veut empêcher
l'appréciation qu'on a d'autres
solutions mais sont plus embêtante parce
que si on joue b6 bas on se met le pion
sur la visée du fou c'est pas terrible
et si on joue à cinq on affaiblit la
classe b 5
là on donne en avant-poste magnifique
alain cavalier blanc qui n'en demandait
pas tant et qui va attaquer la dame non
plus en se plaçant sur cette case
exactement la dame est obligé de jouer
au baby temps plus pour garder un oeil
sur le pion des six donc c'est pas c'est
pas terrible ce pas terrible non car il
ya cinq explique du coup parce qu'il ya
une vraie menace est bon pourquoi pas
donc finalement au lieu d'échanger les
cavaliers au centre les échanges sur le
côté donc c'est sans doute un peu mieux
pour les blancs c'est pour ça que l'on
ne choisit cette cette suite après
cavale et prend assez d'emprunts 5 et
puis la lune est une idée en tête mais
sur un an maintenant et on va le voir on
va attendre un peu mais on va le voir
donc il a réussi a finalement éloigné la
dame noire de la case ses sept pour
qu'elle vienne en a cinq
à noter que cette dame est finalement
toutes les cases ici sont prises par les
blancs donc son action latéral et pas
forcément très très forte
alors il a quand même un contrôle sur
re5 parce que oui il pourrait y avoir eu
5 ha oui avec des attaques du cavalier
ouverture de la colonne et ensuite le
fou eux cédé 7 pour être en prise par la
dame d un ben oui oui oui il faut
heureusement que la dame bon c'est cette
eau si oui on sait c'est de protéger
aussi voilà ouais non il faut toujours
avoir mené sur l'a351 parce que toujours
en a sept variantes qu'il faut toujours
faire attention avec les noirs la
poussée f5 voilà pousser ou 5
inversement pour les blancs il faut
toujours avoir un oeil sur la poussée e5
est ou alors sur la poussée des cinq
aussi et tout et tout et bien dérouillé
donc là en maintenant un an de fini son
développement on peut dire avec le
ku'damm détroit pourquoi parce que bien
il sort sa dame de sa première case donc
il a développé puis de il a enfin
connectés les tours après avoir fait le
rock donc il a suivi tous les grands
préceptes de l'ouverture et kasparov
aussi puisque regardez vous avez les
deux tours qui sont connectés voyez
comment de façon harmonieuse il faut en
étant à la fois précis dans les coups
mais développer les pièces correctement
de façon à être actif au maximum de 70
de son potentiel tour à des 8
alors c'est toujours bien de mettre une
tour en vis-à-vis de la dame pourquoi
pas on s'est vite ma foi oui pourquoi
pas il aurait pu aussi la mettre ensuite
avec action sur la colonne c'est mais
peut-être qu'il avait pas il a peut-être
qu'ici
caspar n'a pas vu d'opportunités
d'améliorer cette pression sur la
colonne parce que il y en a on n'a plus
le justement le cavalier en général
quand on joue sur la colonne c'est avec
les noirs dans ce type d'ouverture on
aime jouer justement cavalia 5 avait
laissé quatre qui justement pose des
problèmes de positionnement du fou de
caisses noires ben là c'est pas le cas
il ya plus de cavaliers donc peut-être
qu'il a estimé que cette colonne c'est
pas très utile et il valait mieux mettre
la tour en vis-à-vis dame donc ici
regardez faut pas se tromper de tourin
bien aux échecs
ici on regardait tour ft1 donc ses sept
tours qui vient ici pourquoi parce qu'il
veut garder celle là au contact du pion
à 4 il a une majorité pions
alors voilà ça paraît logique que le jeu
des blancs se déroule quand même plutôt
vers les dames s'appelait fou regarde
vers l'élevage
voilà donc de manière générale il ya
plutôt des raisons de garder cette tour
on a exactement donc ça peut être un
thème puisque vu que les noirs justement
ne sont pas allés sur la colonne c est
bien il quelque part ils ont renoncé à
faire pression un peu sur les dab alors
donne côté ce que les blancs peuvent
attaquer sur les loin oui mais peut-être
que les noirs attendre que ça pour créer
des faiblesses parce que j'avance mes
pions oui je peut déstabiliser ce
cavalier oui mais est-ce qu'après
derrière j'ai quelque chose et si j'ai
rien mais j'ai affaibli mme roy donc si
la position s'ouvre après ça peut être
très embêtant bon alors pour éviter un
je préfère garder ma tour à actions
allaient le dames et après fou ces six
des noirs alors on joue pouces et 6
bien sûr pour faire pression sur eux 4
mais aussi pour protéger la case dessin
qui est protégé par le cavalier par le
fou par le pion aux six par la dame à 5
donc ça peut être leur plus tard de
jouer le coup des 5
d'autant plus qu'elle à tour derrière et
la dame blanche en vis-à-vis voilà alors
sur des 5 e on peut tenter de jouer des
coups comme eux cinq pour éviter
justement une ouverture qui serait
extrêmement dangereuses et mais là le
câble est maintenant une quasi justement
il publie en même 4 puis on peut
envisager le cas pourquoi pas oui c'est
vrai puisque aprica méprend puis on
prend la dame est attaqué le pion est
protégé il faudrait trouver une case
pour la dame tout à fait donc des 5
pourquoi pas mais c'est aux blancs de
jouer et c'est là que la conception d'un
land se révèle alors regardez bien vous
voyez comme un an des quand même un
joueur précis ces jolis coups des quatre
pas mal pas mal du tout des 4 alors
peut-être un peu inattendu pour kasparov
je sais pas mais au vu de la suite sans
doute que oui parce que là que fait la
dame
alors imaginons que la dame prennent le
pion b4 parce que c'est une grand mythe
c'est un pion qu'on peut prendre
d'accord pourrait faire une première
chose c'est de se dire je vais attaquer
la dame l'a harcelé en emparer de la
colombe et ouais mais bien sûr on peut
faire retour à b1 tout simplement
et où va la dame la dame plus revenir en
a 5 et mais pas pour longtemps puisque
après damas cinq hommes le fameux qu'est
ce qu'on avait dit à l'heure c'est
qu'effectivement ce fouillis viser la
case b6 et c'est fini abandon kasparov
peut aller se rhabiller et préparer la
partie suivante
donc ça va vite voyez des quatre c'est
mort il n'y a pas de coups parce que sur
dame prend des quatre tours à b1 le solo
de coucy devenir ans à 3 moyen 4 3 elle
est mal placée c'est facile ainsi damas
trois à bien tout simplement vous
trouverez deux complètement et c'est
fini la dame n'a plus de gaz ici c'est
le fou là c'est la tour ici c'est le
cavalier tac
là bas c'est toujours le cavalier et
puis là c'est encore la tour et là c'est
l'autre tour et dans là on est un peu
dans le camp bleu en général tout est
bien protégé oui donc elle est foutue
donc la partie est terminée et kasparov
peut commander son dessert pour aller
dans sa chambre dams et 7 et forcé et la
voilà c'est bien parce que ça justifie
la position de la tour ici puisqu'on est
du côté où ça bouge
notamment on a créé déjà un petit une
petite attaque et puis surtout que c'est
pas fini
puis la colonne à risque de s'ouvrir
donc la tour blanche étant déjà sur
cette colonne ah mais oui ça va s'ouvrir
ici parce que regarder le coup c b 5
alors b5 et très fort le fou peut pas
reculer comme ça puisque on perdrait le
pion à 6 puis après sans doute le pion
b71 quoi qu'il faut faire attention aux
cavaliers ont pour jouer fois ci ça fout
17 c'est possible dans ce cas là
on peut continuer par à 5 pour menacer
fou b6 tout simplement parce qu'il n'ya
pas de risque ici il ya entreprises du
cavalier donc b4 dames c'est cette baie
5 belles food et 7 quand même il faut
baisser quand même en fait avec la wii
en fait il vous faut des sept îles a pas
repris en fait mais où ici reprend alors
s'il reprend va regarder si les noirs
reprennent tout simplement ont fait
apprendre des 5 fu 17 et forcé fcp 6 ab
on peut jouer mais s'ils sont malades à
main alors si la dame revient sur ces 6
ou 5 attaques du fou estran et attaques
du khalife 6 c'est mort donc la dame
serait obligé de revenir sur la huitième
en gs qui est jamais bon de lacunes tour
qui pourrait aller s'arrimer
tranquillement à cette halle attendant
les renforts qui viendrait d un square
oui en plus des 7 sera attaqué toujours
soir cinq cavaliers qui peut mener cette
entrée assez haut rhin les cinq c'est le
rhume se serait plié
ça serait horrible donc b4 dames c'est
cette baie 5 dont il est fou 17 respect
on voit tout ça donc ils évitent cette
variante il joue fou 17 et là avait
tombé un mois la tranquille même pas mal
peut-être que d'autres possibilités sont
à l'ordre du jour b prend 1,6 ou
pourquoi pas à 5
une menace foulée 6 et gagne 1 de la
qualité donc ça peut être très dangereux
aussi
bon c'est tout va bien et bien puisqu'on
continue on menace si on prend à 6 suivi
de foot des six up qualité donc à
prendre les 5 que maintenant très bien à
noter que c'est mieux maintenant pour
presque mieux maintenant pour kasparov
parce que s'il est blanc reprennent du
plomb eh bien il ya la tournée plus sur
la colonne ouverte
voyez comme il faut être malin c'est
précis c'est tout mieux donc cavale et
prend b 5 mai où il prend du cavalier
parce que ce qu'avait dit pour l'instant
ben il attendait que ça de pouvoir créer
des menaces dans le clan ennemi le pion
au 4t bien protégé de toute façon le jeu
n'est plus tellement de ici tout de
suite d'attaqués de tous sur la case de
notamment des 5 mai d'aller maintenant
créer des menaces contre le nouveau pion
faible le pion bessette qui est tout
seul
surtout qu'après qu'elle allait prendre
b5 et bien la pression est telle que les
noirs n'ont pas trop le choix puisque ce
cavalier attaques y compris le pion des
6 après un coup que me fous des six la
tour b 8 c'est la fascination objet de
bougies n'ont trouvé prendre le pire on
fait un bref ça se compliquerait très
très vite
alors il faut prendre donc il faut
prendre les se débarrasser de ce
cavalier
il renaît comme un dandy ci ne fait pas
n'importe quoi faut être précis il ne
prend ni à les prendre a dit que le pion
jones gagne ça serait une erreur on
boucherait la colonne de la tour mais
bien sûr il promet la dame malin puisque
sur dame prend b5 et bien on menace le
fameux v6 gagne la tour et on menace
aussi dans le premier set
accessoirement et accessoirement
d'apprendre 17 alors par contre on
laisse le pion ces deux tout seul alors
qu'est-ce qui se passe il faut regarder
qu'après vu un homme sur dame prend
c'est de ça c'est très important
ben ouais y voit la dame à nouveau
toujours regardé tout et prix peut aller
on a deux ici c'est pris ici ses prix
donc il n'y a plus que la dame en a deux
qui peut être jouer tout simplement ont
joué un tour et c'est fini la dame n'a
plus de gaz puisque la colonne b est
prise par la dame la colonne a été prise
par la tour la colonne s'est éprise par
la tour qu'est ce qui reste comme case
il y en a plus assez pris par le fou ça
aussi c'est mort tout est pris donc la
dame éprise
décidément
donc d'en prendre mes cinq tours à huit
de kasparov donc kasparov et c'est bon
il faut bien qu'il peut pas prendre ici
donc il veut faire pression c'est vrai
que le pion à 4 peut être considéré
comme un pion faible mais anne on ne se
presse pas à noter qui peut toujours
protégé ce pion en juin des coups comme
fou mais si suivi 2 à 5
mais avant il veut protéger ce plan
parce que si le foot samba la manoeuvre
convient de voir ne marche plus puisque
dame prend tous riches tôt qu'on peut
venir en d2 et puis on attaquait f4 et
là alors là par contre attention c'est
compliqué ça saigne versé sans réponse
acr clés noires auraient l'initiative ce
serait un désastre non on joue ses
quatre adjoints c4 mais on protège le
pion ces deux par l'adam dame protège
ses 4 puis on tue dans l'oeuf un peu le
contre jeu qui serait éventuellement
possible par des cinq ont eu aussi bien
sûr toute velléité de ceux effectivement
de se réveiller avec les noirs par le
coût des scènes qui libérerait le fou et
qui pourrait essayer de créer du contre
jour au centre donc là maintenant caspar
en fait très mal
c'est à dire que là il faut trouver
quelque chose alors ils auraient pu
essayer par exemple de jouer d'un mât 5
avec l'idée de harceler d'attaquer ce
pion à 4 quoique aussi est ce que c'est
une vraie attaque puisqu'on attend
toujours bessette mais williams ou 6 sur
cinq c'est que lecavalier
il n'a pas de gaz dire qu'ici bas oui
oui ouvelle cavaliers hussein trouve à
lecavalier
si on prend en prendre c'est pareil pour
le carrelet regardez ici ses prix par la
dame est pas ici on fait les changes se
sera pris par la tour donc même les
changes de préalables dédain ne suffit
pas alors si on échange
ah oui c'est pris par cette tour là si
on prend ça oui mais oui ici si on prend
ici prise prise même si on échangerait
dame qui la dame ne contrôle plus les
sept cas l'autre tour qu'ils contrôlent
c'est quand même très embêtant aussi
donc sur ces 4 on peut pas vraiment
continuer à attaquer le pion à cinq noms
dont kasparov qu'est-ce qui peut jouer
d'autres mais rien c'est terrible alors
s'il joue on peut essayer pour eux ces
huit attaques avec les deux pièces
lourdes le pion c4 et c'est pareil on
peut toujours voir lecavalier maintenant
une case en 8 mai un peut-être voir la
variante alors peut-être que ie8 on peut
jouer qui lui tournait pas obligé de
prendre puisque le cavalier protège le
pion des 6 et ça fait mal évidemment on
voit bien la puissance ici donc on va
jouer par exemple d'en prendre 17 et
puis il le fou f3 et réveiller contre la
torah 8 la menace c'est de prendre
simplement faux contre tours et là
surtout reprendre 1,4 par exemple pour
sortir de cette menace
on échange mais là on peut échanger les
dames et après tout reprend ses 7 ans
n'entre en huitièmes avec la tour europe
et le tout le cavalier tant en prise on
est obligé de jouer 3 f 8
et comme il est comme il est cloué on
peut faire reprend dès 6 ans
c'est l'horreur c'est l'horreur puisque
fou prend tout reprend le collier peut
pas reprendre on n'a pas peur d'un échec
on peut toujours jouer soit fou juin
soit revenir avec la tour donc il ya
aucun problème de math nul part pour les
blancs
c'est les noirs au contraire qu'ils
perdent une pièce ici qu'est ce qu'on
peut faire si on sort le fou et bien
cédé 7 et ses maths où l'on prend la
tour c'est ma tante pour l'atome bref on
gagne tout couac bref donc sur ces 4 et
bien voyez qu'il a pas beaucoup de cours
et sparrow fond c'est déjà un problème
de quasi du gang
donc il joue un des rares qu'il reste 5
alors au cinq a du mérite parce que cinq
ans pêche aux sacs empêche que les
blancs eux mêmes jouent au sexe est
protégé par transparence avec la dame et
surtout mais sa bouche l'avenir de ce
fou parce que on bloque le pion à 4
donc voilà ce fou maintenant est un fou
qui est un peu plus endormis qu'ils ne
l'étaient mais c'est au moulin de jouer
il faut b6 quand même tout b6 donc on
l'avait dit tout à l'heure foulée 6 on
pourra ensuite poussé à 5
et ça va être un peu pénible alors
qu'est ce qui se passe sur dame c6 il
aurait pu jouer dame c6 kasparov pour
essayer d'alléger sa position proposée
pourquoi pas un échange de dames et bien
on peut continuer tout simplement par à
on peut échanger là et d'avoir le point
qui serait un pion passé voilà oui c'est
vrai on peut aussi choisir de prendre
les dames avant surnomment ses 6
effectivement on peut prendre en c6
alors moi j'aime pas trop prendre à ces
sites ça ramène le pion b sur le sur le
jeu et mais on a quand même dû en passer
donc s'il est très fort ce pion il va
immobiliser la tour à la défense et en
attendant on va pouvoir créer des
menaces sans doute vers le centre donc
c'est pénible donc sur food et six
classes pour choisi de jouer aux dames
6,8 il veut pas souffrir dans une finale
sans espoir il
il met sa dame aussi sur la casse et 8
pour essayer de tenir le plus longtemps
possible et de ce soit le plus difficile
aussi pour un nombre de l'emporter s
prend 2,5 les prendre 5
alors attention ici on pourrait
envisager dame prend 5 au 6 mai bon ben
ça laisse tout simplement je pense le
pion à quatre ça c'est pas l'idée depuis
un vis-à-vis du tour dames qui oui en
plus ça vis-à-vis tourna mais le fou est
pas vraiment decazeville pour ne peut
pas vraiment attaquer a ajouté sur blanc
donc c'est pas trop gênant c'est surtout
la perte de points 4 on n'a pas envie
parce que notre +14 on voit bien que
c'est un candidat il n'y a plus que le
pion bessette à faire sauter donc des
prend 1,5 et simplement à 5 voilà et
l'a5 on peut maintenant menace oui on
crée la menace de prendre le pion aux
cinq stères conte à protéger nos pions
et l'a d'ailleurs fuite en jouant un
faux et fuite kasparov protège le pion à
5 donc bilan des courses après 7
combine cette langue combinaison d'un an
à commencer par b4 et bien les blancs
beaucoup d espace une dame dessin qui
est très bien placée avec beaucoup de
beaucoup d'actions sur le point 5 sur
cette diagonale et si l'on contrôle sans
partage de la colonne des examens et de
la case des 8
oui on peut pas échanger les tours
puisque bien sûr le fourbe et si ce
contrôle
en fait il ya que le football un f3 qui
est un petit peu inactifs pour l'instant
pour l'instant mais on a la fameuse
aussi père de fou à noter que d'ailleurs
kasparov aime bien jouer à lui avec la
paire de fou donc forcément il n'aime
pas forcément que l'adversaire les la
paire de fou c'est toujours un avantage
notamment quand on se dirige vers des
finales parce que les fous contrôle à
distance des couleurs des deux cases des
deux côtés de couleur pardon et en cela
à voir les deux fous et souvent
supérieurs affoué cavaliers donc h3 bon
petit coup tranquille d'argent qui se
ménage gagne petit voyez comme il n'est
pas pressé maintenant il sait qu il al
avantage dont qui consolide sa position
en jouant à eux trois ils évitent les
matchs du couloir mais il évite des
tentatives de manoeuvre base du cavalier
g4 il évite d éventuels cavaliers g4
hawks a menacé par un chose poisson mais
n'est-ce pas grand chose on peut essayer
d'aider tour me vois la tour et puis sur
sur les échanges d'entrée de l'adamant
g4 et ici ça va pousser vite attention
quand même donc dames 6 bompas part au
fait c'est de d'améliorer la position de
ces pièces aussi lui aussi tous les
messieurs les deux joueurs donc dames 6
il sort ici il vient la défense des
cases centre à nice et améliorer la
pression de saddam et relie heroes lycée
tour entraîne il vaut mieux que ce
soient les tours qu'ils soient liés et
la regarder magnifique ou d'amande par
tour des 5 millions 7 et fils de qualité
positionnelle extrêmement classique
alors c'est un sacrifice de qualité
pourquoi parce que les noirs me
surprendre avec le cavalier alors que
vient faire la tournée 5
elle prépare éventuellement le
doublement des tours sur la colonne des
pourquoi pas préparé le doublement des
tours si les noirs ne font rien
elle rajoute de la pression sur le pion
aux cinq il ya une petite pression
supplémentaire effectivement sur le plus
ancien mais qui pour l'instant est
défendu deux fois
bon c'est pas forcément le meilleur
je sais pas sur dame 6 il aurait pu
aussi doubler les tours ou simplement en
jouant autour des 3 et tous rêvent d un
pour essayer pourquoi pas de provoquer
des échanges en limite c'est peut-être
le but d'un homme parce que s'il ya des
échanges
finalement il est bien en main il suffit
que ça saute
et puis là un pion qui va vite adam et
je veux aussi je vous directement c'est
simple parce qu'on se demande bien ce
que peuvent jouer les noirs derrière on
pourrait le coup de tenter ses seins qui
boucherait l'avenir de son fou c'est
embêtant parce qu'on pourrait pas
revenir si vous c5 qui on voit pas trop
où il va apprendre qu est-ce qu il ne
peut pas jouer vraiment ces six bons
mets donc il mais leur prix augmenter là
mais le retour des trois il peut à la
fois doublé sur b3 ou double et sur d un
bon il choisit un couple tout en une
tour des cinq qu'un avantage c'est que
ça immobilise la tour e 8 6 a pas si les
noirs with that there on peut pas jouer
tous ces huit pas rien le pouf puisque
on perdrait le pion de 5
donc là mais que ce soit sur l'occasion
parce que voyez que tommy lee étouffé il
a pas de coups il est sous pression
donc il choisi d'accepter le sacrifice
de qualité d'un land pions cavaliers
prend des 5
mais pourquoi pas et après eux prendre
des 5 il faut bouger la dame donc la
classe par off en jouant dame g6 bien un
petit oeil ici sur la tour elle reste
ici de côté au moins pourquoi pas
envisager plus tard aussi devenir par
exemple chez par angers 5 et 6 les noirs
les blancs abandonne la première rangée
on peut on peut faire des échecs échec
et tenter un petit perpétuelle pour
arracher le nul
exactement une position un peu difficile
bon ceci dit il a une qualité est là un
kasparov
oui donc c'est quand même tendu ce café
landes à nantes a aussi lié d'options
qui étaient isolés
voilà il y en a fait une c'est à dire
que maintenant effectivement en
reprenant du pion en plus il a libéré
son fou et l'a libéré le fou qui
maintenant vise bessette
voilà c'est à dire qu'une fois que l'or
la menace a maintenant ça peut être ces
cinq des six les des pions qui vont vite
adam et surtout un fou qui attaque 17
bon à noter aussi qu'en g6 ici avec la
tour il adam les noirs vont pouvoir
jouer eux 4 qui va tuer
l'action de ce foin donc il ya quand
même un peu de jeu pour kasparov mais on
va voir que ça suffit pas puisque après
ses cinq qui fait le coup normal
maintenant met en branle à notre
majorité de pions passé ils sont
quasiment passer maintenant
les sept tiendra pas on va jouer ces 6
puis on prend bien on prend et ça y est
on n'est plus qu'à 2 càs de fermes
atteint de faire dame
un fait qui dit dame dit matt et très
vite il faut que tu aies on vient de le
voir il faut tuer l'action de ce fou qui
est quand même extrêmement dangereux
donc 4e 4 c'est pas tellement mais sûr
il ya aussi ce plan qui peut s'avérer
dangereux mais certainement sujet
puisque après fou et deux bombes et ceux
plus on avancera pas il est bloqué par
le fou le fouillis protégé par la dame
ça va être très dur pour les noirs de
contourner ça pour l'instant il ya qu
une pièce qui peut jouer dans le camp
blanc c'est celle à tour les tours pour
l'instant c'est la dame les tourelles
sont confinés ainsi que le fou mais on a
bloqué l'action de ce fou c'est surtout
ça l'idée bien sûr donc tours 5
la kasparov maintenant elle veut pas
rester en défense ils jouent tour sait
qu il peut avoir l'idée de simplement
essayé de contre attaquer bon on va
pouvoir défendre
il n'y a pas de gros gros gros soucis
mais une petite attaque
il ya aussi un petit piège si les blancs
jouent des six est bien fou prend des
6es en cas de pions prend tout prendre
aïe donc attention on ne peut pas jouer
n'importe quoi donc dame 17
pas mal hein on joue en jouant m17
protège à la fois tuant quatre donc
prépare pourquoi pas la pousser ses 6
pourquoi pas prendre le pion de 17 est
aussi bon c'est pas plus mal d'avoir un
petit oeil sur h3 puisque ces deux
pièces menace de faire des choses ici
c'est un coup multifonctions ou la dame
est extrêmement active dans le camp noir
donc c'est très très difficile à jouer
tour g5 c'est ce qu'on a dit ben oui il
ya quand même une petite menace noir qui
attention kasparov est un excellent
joueur tactics il voit la moindre
possibilité de sauver la position il va
la trouver
je la trouvais et la sicile à nantes
dans un match de championnat du monde ne
parvient pas à gagner une partie wii
domine même si ça se termine par la
nulle psychologiquement ça serait dur
ça sera dur donc très simplement dingue
j'ai dit bah écoute à toi donc
protection simplement du pian et 10 mais
voilà un qu'es-tu fait parce que là moi
je vais préparer dame prend et après on
arrête les mes pions c'est impossible
d'arrêter deux pions passé lié oui ça
surtout en cinquième surtout à 5e orangé
et on alterne toujours en plus qui dort
la perte de fouet l avantage de pouvoir
soutenir sur les cases blanches et
noires
l'avancé des pions alternativement ça
fait peur donc kasparov de 3 alors que
trois bien ça très bon ben la protection
de la case f2 on voit pas trop où ils
vont à venir quand même il veut
peut-être joué dame ces deux donc il
fallait libérer ces grenades ou
peut-être 2004 avec un petit oeil dance
et dorés lés avantages éventuels si le
fou se retire de pouvoir à nouveau
avancer le pion on pourrait avancer aux
deux tout à fait dame c2c une dernière
chance petite chance tactile de reims et
as france et 5 français 5e dan français
sont là aussi ça ouais c'est vrai tout à
fait dams et de aussi attaque le pion c5
avec le fou donc le coup suivant donnant
pousse déjà enlève cette possibilité sur
dame ces deux bombes et s'attaque plus
vraiment ces cinq avec le font en tout
cas avec la tour oui je peux envisager
rendant la qualité si c'est possible
bon alors là il faut regarder pourquoi
qu'asseoir ne jouerez pas ici dames
ces deux il faut regarder ses variantes
c'est parce qu'il a joué mais il faut
quand même jeter un oeil et bien
simplement regarder d'en prendre mais
cette attaque
la tour donc si les noirs prennent le
fou je prends la tour et je suis plus
qu'à deux cases offert dame sans
possibilité d'autant que je peux pousser
17 menacé dame prend fou échec suivi de
dames et si la tour se poussent en plus
8 par exemple lors si la tour 20,8
maintenant la dame qui est sûre caisse
blanche peut revenir je peux en je peux
envisager exactement je peux y en
envisager de revenir en f3 ou alors de
pousser 17 ans u17 aussi c'est bien moi
j'ai mis ce 17 parce que voilà toi il ya
plus de cases
alors s'il a tout ressemble à ces dames
je peux voyez ça va très très vite donc
sur 2,6 alors on va quand même regarder
dame ces deux dames prendre bessède
avoir quand même regarder ce qui se
passe sur dame prend fou ça me prend de
fouilles a pas de menace nos tares
regardez là comme la dame en plus
protège toujours donc on fait d'emprunts
en 8es rien et on menace toujours de
faire d'amande au coût des sept des huit
que faire donc ici s'il est
alors les noirs peuvent jouer alors
peut-être dam des deux avec l'idée tu
peux pas pousser 17 puisque dame prend
17 et je menace eu deux dames et
attention
je peux quand même créer au moins un
échec perpétuelle est peut-être plus
donc que font les blancs on à cette
position
on va regarder simplement des coups
comme peut-être 24 ici recentralisation
de la dame contrôle ici des pions à
noter que le pion pourra pas pousser
jusqu'en mai puisqu'il ya la fois la
tour et la dame qui protège donc dans le
cadre c'est bien ça suffit il ya des
coups d'oeil à d'autres coûts plus
agressif comme fou des huit qui est
possible des huit qui pose la question à
la tour par exemple sur food et 8 ici où
va la tour si on joue le coup et si ce
qui semble normal à la fois on évite les
maths du couloir on protège la tour eh
bien regardez l'idée c'est de jouer et
fouet cet ail c'est foutu on va tout
prendre et l'attaquent continue donc
voyez ça marche pas donc kasparov tente
un dernier truc qui joue le tour j'ai
trois alors tour g3 ces colis des îles
et c'était de jouer dans le 4 et puis de
jouer tours tourcoing je crois alors oui
de jouer ou d'un match si c'est pour
prendre trois si la dame s'en va par
exemple ici dame prend 17 c'est la
partie et simplement sur à oui il joue
dames 6 kasparov ici voilà honda me suis
un petit oeil sur le 17
et s'il doit me prends à hisser mat
attention tout reproche trois oui on va
montrer quand même si maintenant si à
nantes joue dans prend mais non c'est
pas le but
regardez tout reprend échec puis on
prend forcé et high damage trois matches
ça fait mal quand on a une position pas
rien c'est donc sur d'un bep cette dame
attention la petite menacé il faut parer
cette menace assez facile dans le rouage
de tranquille et l'abandon tout
simplement parce que qu une fois de plus
remis aux normes
à ces dames à 5,5 on peut encore jouer
dans le cinq puisque les guides et dames
5 c'est d'avoir découvert mais il n'y a
pas de crainte en fait dans huit rien
apprendre sur le découvert et on fait
quoi sur la découverte avait en fait
rien puisque si je fais tout rejet six
échecs en prochain --après à toi il se
passe rien se passe rien la dame et la
tour contrôle g2 et encore les deux fous
les pions exactement l'eau après 3h de
kasparov se rend à l'évidence il le
savait déjà
en fait dès que dès qu'il commence à
essayer de monter sa tour c'est une
attaque désespérée comme on en fait au
cas où mais il savait déjà que
positionne helmand disons ils étaient
perdus
donc une très belle partie d'un land qui
a été une attaque de type positionnelle
avec l'aide du coup tactique b4 des
cartes qui était un coup très très fort
on est très forts camille kasparov
lui-même sous pression voilà voilà donc
un an de passe et pas n'importe qui ah
bah non pas devenu champion du monde
voilà donc c'est sur cette magnifique
victoire
danang où que vous pourrez mais sur
étudier plus en détails vous même à
l'idée de votre votre ordinateur
non non la main à l'ancienne à
l'ancienne pour cent des baryons faut
pas regarder lord il faut pas regarder
l'ordinateur donc c'est sûr cette
victoire donc qu on va se quitter sur
cette émission dit ronald télé spéciale
champion de l'histoire du jeu d'échecs
est ici c'était la carrière du champion
du monde en titre en 2012 au moment où
cette vidéo est enregistrée ce ne sera
pas le cas quand elle sera vue en 2037
mais on ne serait jamais et voilà on se
quitte merci jérôme insisté femmes merci
à vous de nous avoir suivi sur des
konaté et puis je vous dis à bientôt
pour une autre émission sur les
champions de l'histoire du jeu d'échecs
au revoir au revoir